die app für flüchtlinge 1 meter 70
langer skorpion entdeckt und strom durch
urin
das sind nur drei der fünf themen jetzt
in den club top news die ganze
diskussion entdeckt er wurde bis zu 1
meter 70 lang und hatte einen etwas
seltsamen körperbau von rund 460
millionen jahren lebte er wer der
pendelbus dekore hansis diesen
entdeckten amerikanische wissenschaftler
erst vor kurzem und vor allem zum
allerersten mal im fachmagazin bmc
evolutionary biology sprachen die
wissenschaftler über ihren fund und über
dessen seltsame körper war ungewöhnlich
ist besonders die größe das penta zrsd
cora hansis hier übrigens zu der gattung
der see skorpione gehört vor 250
millionen jahren sind diese tiere
ausgestorben
die wissenschaftler sind vom körperbau
total fasziniert zitat die neue spezies
ist außerordentlich bezahlt so der
biologe james längste kleider machen
leute einer neuen umfrage zufolge macht
aber auch farbe leute ganze 1000
probanden wurden zu ihrer farben wahl
befragt ergebnis 66 prozent der
befragten frauen wollen an männern die
farbe schwarz sehen
sie würde für intelligenz und sicherheit
stehen pink dagegen halten die meisten
der befragten für eine er im wahrsten
sinne des wortes unkluge entscheidung
wer pink trägt sei eben nicht besonders
klug was die farbe rot bewirkt das
hatten wir ja schon mal in einem video
erzählt wer kann sich noch erinnern
genau attraktivität ist das stichwort
mit dem smartphone zudem behörden das
soll schon bald vielen flüchtlingen
ermöglicht werden zwei unternehmerinnen
aus dresden betty rotter heinrich und
viola klein haben sich einem großen
problem der in deutschland ankommenden
flüchtlinge gewidmet die fragen zu
welcher behörde muss ich gehen
wie läuft das ganze verfahren ab wie
bekomme ich die informationen die ich
gerade benötige was darf ich was darf
ich nicht und viele weitere fragen
werden in einer app beantwortet die eppo
wahlkampf zu dresden willkommen in
dresden gibt den betroffenen die
entsprechenden antworten aktuell gibt es
diese app leider nur für dresden aber es
sollen noch weitere
für andere städte folgen das schlägt auf
den magen plastik in den weltmeeren den
massen an müll sind besonders die dort
lebenden tiere ausgeliefert die
forschungsorganisation zero hat dazu
erschreckende zahlen erarbeitet ihre
ergebnisse stellten sie im fachmagazin
proceedings of the national academy of
sciences of the united states of america
pnas vor
demnach sei in 35 jahren fast kein
seevogel mehr zu finden der keinerlei
plastikrückstände in sich trägt fast die
hälfte aller seevogel gattung sind von
dem müll stark bedroht aktuell würden
rund fünf billionen plastikstücke in den
weltmeeren schreiben die theorien strom
erzeugen
ja das funktioniert tatsächlich der
professor für bioenergie und nachhaltige
systeme an der university of west
england in bristol johannes europolis
konnte zusammen mit seinen kollegen eine
apparatur bauen die das ermöglicht in
der fachzeitschrift physical chemistry
chemiker physiker berichteten sie
darüber den forschern zufolge sei die
menge urin aus einer gefüllten blase
schon ausreichend um zu telefonieren
aber wie funktioniert das bakterien
oxidieren mit den bestandteilen des
urins und setzten so elektronen frei
fertig zitat letztlich nutzt das system
ein teil der biochemischen energie die
beim wachstum der mikroben entsteht um
sie direkt in elektrizität umzusetzen so
johannes euro plus skurrile technik aber
sie funktioniert und jetzt geht es um
etwas das funktioniert auch ich bin
jetzt auch auf dem kanal von volkswagen
financial services zu sehen die kollegen
habe ich mich gefragt ob ich nicht
finanzthemen genauso einfach erklären
könnte die wissenschaftsthemen auf
meinem pixum kanal und die
herausforderung habe ich gerne
angenommen allerdings und wer dich
unterstützt von experten von volkswagen
financial services die mir zum beispiel
themen erklären wie wie sprich auf eine
weltreise oder wie bezahlen mit dem
smartphone wie geht das mit einer
immobilie und so weiter und so fort
also wenn euch das interessiert schaut
vorbei auf dem kanal von volkswagen
financial services abonniert ihn und ich
freue mich auf euch